le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
protéger la biodiversité de notre île
une mission menée conjointement par
plusieurs acteurs et par plusieurs
actions chaque année l'opération nuit
sans lumière est l'occasion de mettre en
avant une espèce emblématique et menacée
les pétrels organisée par le parc
national et la seor le département
soutient cette initiative
[Musique]
là c'est un bon jour vous avez trouvé un
oiseau c'est ça et ben si vous pouvez
écrire sur la boîte aux numéros 1257 et
j'en vois quelqu'un dans la journée
voilà à peine une demi-heure que le
centre est ouvert et julie a déjà reçu
dix appels et à chaque sonnerie
c'est un oiseau supplémentaires à
récupérer donc là on va chez les
pompiers de saint-andré pour récupérer
deux oiseaux les jeunes pétrels
également les pétrels adultes s'oriente
grâce à remonter de la lune et des
étoiles sur sur la mer et cantiques
ignorent que leur terrier et comme une
niche au niveau du piton des neiges
ils sont désorientés à cause de la
barrière lumineuse se trouve sur la côte
donc ce qu'on appelle la pollution
lumineuse et quand ils sont désorientés
ils vont tourner autour de la zone
éclairée jusqu'à ses cheveux au sol
incapable de re décoller l'oiseau ne
doit son salut qu'à la vigilance des
habitants
une fois l'animal mise à l'abri il est
déposé chez les pompiers ou la seor peut
le récupérer
[Musique]
julie va ramener les deux jeunes échoué
au centre de soins ils seront examinés
numérotés et relâché et voilà en outre
depuis le début de la saison
la société d'études ornithologiques de
la réunion ainsi pu récupérer 300 jeunes
pétrels c'est pour réduire ce nombre que
les nuits sans lumière ont été créés le
principe réduire la pollution lumineuse
en éteignant tout simplement les
lumières alors les nus sans lumière ont
démarré en 2009 avec juste une heure
d'extinction puis nous avons augmenté
cette période d'extinction surtout pour
les pétrels et on a décidé de mettre la
période des nues sans lumière en plein
dans le pic d'envol des pétrels qui a lu
en avril pour savoir que c'est plus de
1000 oiseaux qui sont récupérés pendant
cette période donc l'émission lumière
permettent d'atténuer
échouage aujourd'hui 19 communes sur 24
participent à l'opération
d'autres collectivités comme le
département de la réunion soutiennent
l'initiative
nous avons procédé à l'extraction de nos
bâtiments notamment le musée de villèle
le palais de la source la villa du
département et tous les autres bâtiments
administratifs donc du département pour
montrer notre volonté de faire avancer
les choses et de montrer aussi aux
réunionnais qui a une prise de
conscience à voir aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est important
de mettre l'accent sur cette dangerosité
et de dire aux gens que il faut
continuer il faut que la réunion même
dans le fénoir nous pensent que nous les
nains environnement que nous leurs
protégés non seulement aux pétales de
barreaux mais aussi la planète tout
simplement le département communique
aussi sur l'événement à travers ses
différents sites comme le jardin
botanique de mascarin à saint leu
[Musique]
est ce que vous savez qu est ce qui se
passe en ce moment à la réunion
effectivement on est dans la période
d'ennemis sans lumière les équipes
profitent des visites guidées pour
sensibiliser le public à cette
initiative
dites vous même certains d'entre vous
vous êtes gêné par ses lumières de
nickel autre animal peut être dérangé
nous au niveau du jardin botanique on a
plusieurs actions n'a une action
effectivement de sensibilisation des
visiteurs au cours de nos visites
guidées on a une action de
sensibilisation des jardiniers et du
personnel puisqu'il voit aussi le site
voit ses lumières s'éteindre et puis on
a une action dans le cadre de notre
cycle de conférences est cette année le
jardin botanique veut mettre l'accent
sur une espèce mal connue également
impactés par la pollution lumineuse
nous ce qui nous intéressait pour cette
année c'est de pouvoir sensibiliser les
gens aux chauves souris puisque les
chauves souris elles ont des propriétés
et souvent on est sur des tas mouche ou
souris ça fait peur donc on a la chance
d'avoir maintenant à la réunion une
association qui est le groupe des
chiroptères océan indien et qui se
propose donc de faire des animations et
des conférences et donc on les a
sollicités dans le cadre de notre fille
de conférences pour nous parler des
chauves-souris les chauves souris mais
aussi les tortues marines les insectes
les plantes et même l'homme
tous sont impactés par la pollution
lumineuse pour ces jeunes pétrels il
n'est pas trop tard ce jour-là 23
oiseaux prennent un nouvel envol ils
migreront pendant trois ans à travers le
monde avant de revenir sur leur île
natale qui d'ici là ne braquent aura
peut-être ses projecteurs que sur la
survie de l'espèce
[Musique]
l'opération nuit sans lumière a été
créée en 2009
objectif réduire la pollution lumineuse
pour préserver notamment les pétrels les
tortues marines ou les chauves-souris
l'action s'étend sur 25 jours au mois
d'avril durant le pic d'envol des
pétrels à la réunion dix neuf communes
sur 24 participent à l'opération
en cas de découverte vanoise eau sauvage
en détresse contacter le 02 62 20 46 65
pour plus d'informations rendez vous sur
le site du département au
www.desjardins.com faire
[Musique]